امريكا الوسطى والمناطق الاستوائيه في
المكسيك هي موطن اشجار البابايا وتعد
منطقه اوكساك المكسيكيه اكبر مصدر
للبابايا في العالم
[موسيقى]
ومن على بعد ثلاثه عشر الف كيلو متر نقل
المزارع سعد الله البجالي بذور اشجار
البابايا الى مزرعته الواقعه بمحافظه
الليث غربي السعوديه
على المحافظه وعلى المنطقه وعلى محافظه
الليث منطقه مكه المكرمه بحيث نجيب شيء
يجذب الانظار ويكون له مردود وفائده كثيره
الفاكهه البابايا
حنا وجدنا
التربه والجو مناسب لزراعتها في محافظتنا
فبديت في زراعتها ووجدت انه
فيه فائده عظيمه فبديت ازيد الزراعه
فزرعته الى وصلت الى الفين فاكهه بابايا
موجود عندي في مزرعتي مزرعه الخيط
[موسيقى]
لم يكن يتوقع هذا المزارع في بدايه الامر
ان تنجح زراعه البابايا بمزرعته حتى
تطاولت الاشجار وحصدت الثمار اذ ينتجوا
سنويا
320 طنا عندما نظر على الشتله تستمر اربع
اشهر وتنتج او سته اشهر بالكثير لو طولت
سته اشهر وعاد باقي يستمر انتاجها طول
السنه وعندنا ايضا الماء غزير عندنا ايضا
شجعنا على زراعه البابايا حقيقه اصبحنا
الان
نورد للمملكه العربيه السعوديه والى خارج
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وتلقى البابايا
رواجا كبيرا لدى مرضى القلب والعظام
وحساسيه الجلد لما تحويه من عناصر
وفيتامينات مهمه تعزز من صحتهم
من محافظه الليث سلطان السلمي العربيه